this problem is a worldwide problem
because now apple is not only thinking
about booting Twitter here which would
which would severely hamper our Free
Speech but they are really cracking down
on these protests in China it's rather
extraordinary uh sax went on to talk
about that I just gotta finally ask you
a personal question so you've you've
been in this business at the top of this
business you know all your life
effectively I'm sure you've seen
everything in the tech world were you
shocked to learn that Apple was
preventing
non-violent protesters in China from
communicating with each other
it is pretty shocking because the way
that it was done Tucker was they had a
an update it was like 16.1.1 or
something like that and they didn't say
normally what they do is when they do an
update they put in the the release notes
what they're changing and they said in
the release notes they were changing you
know doing bug fixes and so on they
didn't mention that they were limiting
the use of this airdrop feature normally
Apple is very proud of their releases
and they're eager to tell consumers what
it is that they're doing but in this
case for some reason they didn't mention
it and you have to
okay I know this is a little insidery
Tech stuff but this is super interesting
so we've shown you some of the videos
over the last couple days of what's
going on in China there are massive
protests against their zero covid policy
and because it's a communist country
people don't protest that often because
you know what happens you end up in jail
or you end up getting killed but people
have had enough people are dying because
they're locked in buildings and all this
stuff so what happened was people were
sharing videos using iPhones people were
sharing videos using airdrops so that
you could take a video okay this is a
little technical but this is what was
happening they would take a video and
then using airdrop you could send it to
like everyone around you right and then
they could send it to everyone around
them and everything else so then Apple
put this update in people download the
update they don't put it in the warning
as sax described you know in the little
message when you download an update they
tell you we did this we did that we
fixed this bug we did this they didn't
put it in there and then suddenly they
hampered all of the ability of probably
millions of people in China to be able
to share what's going on on the ground
there why did Apple do that why did Tim
Cook do that
do you think they might work with
governments do you think they might want
to be in bed with the Chinese why is it
that the NBA never says anything bad
about China but will always say bad
things about America do you see how this
is all coming together